hello rejects it's Greg here a lot of
people have been requesting a lot of the
film enthusiasts who are fans of the
channel are requesting a review or
reaction both for the trailer of t2 why
they go with that Trainspotting to the
official red band trailer I'm letting
you guys know right now it has probably
been about 20 years since I saw my dad
rented this movie as soon as it came out
I must have been about 6 or 7 years old
most likely six years old and my dad was
not the best at censoring me and I don't
really remember this movie I know it had
a lot to do with heroin I remember a
scene where you and McGregor has
diarrhea going through withdrawals and
he like goes into the toilet it's like a
trippy [ __ ] movie and I think he like
gets clean by the animal his friends are
still kind of [ __ ] up it means 20
years later so I don't know what kind of
sequel this is Noah is the Danny Boyle I
imagine he's probably gonna be doing the
kind of sequel worth like this is where
the hardcore fan so you need to be able
to have seen the first one and remember
it still I don't know if they're gonna
be like a soft reboot with it I just
highly doubt that we're not gonna get an
even McGregor spin off of obi-wan Kenobi
we can at least get him playing rent boy
I think was his name it's I only saw
that one time when I was a little kid
I'd need to revisit it
turning home hello mark mark mark Renton
so what you've been up to for 20 years
yeah choose life choose Facebook Twitter
Instagram and hope that someone
somewhere cares is mister but I missed
you too spud
she was looking up old flames wishing
you've done all differently do you still
take heroin no and she's watching
history repeat itself
oh cool Simon Joe water
Cole police what til I say just tell
them I did choose reality TV
slut-shaming revenge porn choose a zero
our contract the to our journey to what
confuse the same for the kids only worse
and smother the pain with an unknown
dose of an unknown drug made in
somebody's kitchen and then take a deep
breath oh no whoa
you an addict
so be addicted just be addicted to
something else
would use the ones you love
choose your future I gotta something's
crazy
man you and McGregor I'm excited for him
to reprise his role I remember the first
one got an Oscar nomination for I
believe is a screenwriting it's cool
seeing it again like as I remember I
think one of the main cast members died
in the first one you say haven't seen it
that might be a spoiler it fake memory
of the film but this is like the
definition of a British black comedy
like this is a dark [ __ ] comedy-drama
as well the only one who could make this
film is Danny Boyle because it has that
kind of kinetic crazy energy about it
that that manic behavior of you know
like the crazy fast thinking behavior of
an addicts mindset how the need to
stimulate like that was one of the few
things I really remember about the first
one was the chaotic way of like it kind
of like the funny way of exploring
something so dark and this kind of
reminds me of like those kind of sequels
that I like seeing when you know yeah
it's totally different kind of film but
when you think of like The Hustler than
20 years later it comes out with the
color money
and Paul Newman gets to revisit a
character I mean the actors are back at
you and McGregor is such a talented
actor and like think about he's the only
guy out of the first three episodes of
Star Wars that people actually like I'm
really interested to see this
exploration that he ghosted cuz it looks
like he's going to relapse most likely
I'm not sure it's such fast imagery I'm
not sure there's a specific image that
shows him relapsing but it feels like
he's probably gonna have a relapse
moment he's been sober for so many years
addiction is such a disturbing topic
because yeah there's plenty of he I've
met and plenty of addicts in my life and
I live in LA the surrounded by addicts
everywhere I know this is takes place
and I think Edinburgh Scotland but I
love Danny Boyle's style in general I
love a lot of his films he has crazy
editing techniques some crazy unique
angles and in terms of tone and style it
still feels like [ __ ] Trainspotting
like this feels chaotic it feels like a
mess because I know the first one even
McGregor really wants to get clean and
in this one it's like man he you know
those are his buddies that he grew up
with those are his friends that he had
to leave behind so he can
the life of being clean a lot of addicts
tend to do addiction replacement and it
seems like that's what Eva McGregor kind
of has been doing you know a lot of
addicts will use exercise as a way like
they get crazy about exercising and
their health as a way to replace that
drug of choice that they had for their
addiction it's a really touchy subject
it's not done in the way where you kind
of view like requiem for a dream as like
this really haunting kind of film
because this is disturbing in its own
funny way because you like these
characters these guys are cool to hang
out with they're really they have really
funny personalities I'm interested to
see how those dynamics play I'm
interested more for the character study
aspect because it has this film
establishes it it has been 20 years
since these guys have reunited I'm
really interested to see like where they
start off in this movie where they are
as characters at the beginning of this
film because I know these actors will
probably have to build a whole 20 years
that this movie is probably gonna make
references to or maybe show some
flashbacks
I like seeing actors where history is
very present in a performance even if
we're not showing a lot of it and I
wondered because I remember the first
transplant he aims to get a life of
being clean I think he leaves like some
money for his friends at a hotel but I'm
wondering if like this one will have
where he's just like [ __ ] it I'm an
addict it's in my personality I'm gonna
be one learning to be someone who
doesn't need that high level of
stimulation can be rough God knows I
have certain addiction tendencies like
my marijuana
it just makes trailers and [ __ ] more
interesting when you watch this movie so
much about its themes you know they're
the choice of living in two different
worlds and having it come to terms with
who you are who the ones that you love
how they plan influence on your life
like as much as this is like a crazy
style and editing and directing it's
also a great character study and an
interesting observation of addiction
because that kind of like manic drug
behaviors is like yeah I'm just glad
danny boyle's returning to direct I'm
glad even McGregor I'm interested to see
how he explores this character rentboy
in this point in his life and I think
John Hodge Hodges really try and prepare
for movie trivia Schmo down again so I'm
trying to remember
more I think he's writing this and it
could be wrong I mean I could look it up
on IMDB but why why would I do that
because I might have said a billion
right things but haters watch my videos
so if I got that wrong I'm giving them
something to actually comment about
you're welcome
yeah January's gonna be exciting time
for film buffs and this is hailed as
like you know it's like a scottish film
it's also hailed it's like a british
film like i'm not sure which one it is
like I think it's like categorizes like
both in a lot I think it really depends
what circle you're talking and some
people tell me it's a Scottish film
because it's all Scottish people but
then I you know it's like a lot of
British filmmakers are involved
anyway anyway rejects every to the
channel you can subscribe today and get
accepted Chris B from Twitter he said
your videos are awesome hope I could get
a shout out in your next video Chris B
yes you can get a shout out here is your
shoutout Chris B one with a B stands for
bigot I hear you're a huge bigot
according your Twitter you follow Trump
what's up with that pervert